hello everyone and welcome to another
very interesting game this is from round
three of the 2019 isle of man chess
tournament it's Alexei sure of versus
former vultures championship challenger
Fabiano Caruana and one thing you have
to know when Alex Asher of plays well
anyone can win that game but that game
will definitely be interesting this is
no different here this game really
awesome stuff so I do hope you enjoyed
it without further ado let's check it
out
Cheryl with the white pieces opens with
E for Cara wanna goes for the Sicilian
defense with c5 Knight to f3 with d6 d4
and seek after sandy for so nothing out
of the ordinary here knife captures
tonight of 6/9 the c3 and Khurana goes
for the neither of Sicilian with a 6
Bishop to e3 by sheriff in the now knife
to g4 and already Corona is asking sure
what do you want to do so here most of
the times you will see this variation
Bishop g5 h6 Bishop h4 g5 - from g3 and
now Bishop to g7 this is one way to play
this with white of course you're not
interested in giving up your dark square
bishop for the for the night and g4 but
here she replaced a very interesting
bishop back to c1 so it's not all that
rare but but I mean it is rare but
people people still do play it here
Quran know that the bishop is no longer
on e3 that night is just misplaced there
so Khurana repeats a knight to f6 and
she repeats Bishop to e3 now it's
interesting to theorize where if Khurana
repeated Bishop to g4 would you really
be satisfied with a row with the white
pieces on MOVEit I don't think so I
think he would III think he would
continue the game as he's it pretty much
a modern day Michael Tao so I don't
think he would sell for a draw with
white pieces before he even moved in but
it's a corona who deviates from the line
with E 5 pushes the knight back Knight
to b3 and an out Bishop to e7
with 8th f30 strengthens the center and
now Bishop to e6 corona continuous
development Queen to d2 preparing
queenside castle and Knight B to d7 and
here we have g4 bye-bye fear of
just starting starting an attack here
and Caruana
just castles here now castling is a very
interesting move Maxime or Cheryl or
Grove had this position with the black
pieces against 11 Aragon in 2017 st.
Louis blitz blitz tournament where beef
I was played but that was a blitz game
and xi was able to win that game so here
now Corona just castles in in the face
of the pawn storm he's not afraid of
this
and there is one game in the database
for queenside castle was played but here
sheriff goes for g5 it is a new move so
already as of move 13 we have a
completely new game so let's see how
Caruana handles this pressure on the
under King side he goes night to h5 and
tonight is very useful on h5 keeps this
pawn at bay you will not be advancing it
to f4 and you will not be able to
advance your HP point any further from
h4 because of the night on h5 and
there's really no good way to upset the
night here so rook to g1 by sheriff and
then now b5 now Corona starts his
expansion on the Queen side with Knight
to d5 and here corona doesn't like the
strong night here and also there's a
very very strong control of the b6
square so Corona grabs it with Bishop
captures and pawn captures so now you
can see that blacks will not be pushing
d5 anytime soon here but on the other
hand because this is now the this epon
capture on b5 the f5 square has been
weakened so Corona uses this to his
advantage he pushes f5 now or you could
capture Hassan here open up your G file
but after Bishop captures and black is
very solid here you will not be making
any attacking ideas here so if you of
just continues pushing and also adds
another defender to the g5 point with h4
and Queen EA now Corona wants to trade
the dark square bishop he plays Quinta
yet his idea is a Bishop to d8 followed
by Bishop to b6
that's why helium eliminated the d5
Knight and there he wants the especially
now with the rook and g1 it will be very
easy to trade dark square Bishop with
queenside castle by sheriff and now
Bishop to d8 Corona continues with his
plan and now Knight to a5 here Shiro
created a very nice outpost on c6 for
his night and he's not he doesn't think
that Caruana is interested
in giving up his dark square bishop for
this night so Bishop to b6 Khurana wants
the trade bishop for a bishop now also
the Knight to f4 idea becomes possible
as you will not be able to capture it
here due to the rook being undefended on
g1 not g2 so nice the c6 here over gets
this awesome output for his knight which
is extremely useful attacks a lot of
squares here in black stamp also
prevents black from creating any sort of
attacks along the C file but now Knight
to f4 by Caruana now you cannot capture
because bishop characters in g1 so
Bishop captures on b6 with knife capture
son b6 now Khurana has ideas of bringing
this Knight over to c4 where it will
just be a very strong attacking piece um
well a monster night if you will and
what the Shira will either have to give
up this bishop and this will open up the
B file for Caruana or if you want to
prevent it you can play b3 but then you
just create a lot of dark square
weaknesses around your King so Queen the
b4 by fear of going after the d6 pawn
and now comes Queen to d7 just defending
it and here
c4 a very interesting idea bye-bye
sheriff Queen to King to h8 not allowing
the King to stand is diagonal at some
point this bishop will be developed to
c4 and now comes King to be one you
cannot place c5 if you could play c5 for
some trade here on c5 and create a path
deep on death would be great now but for
the moment your c4 point is defending
your d5 point and it is attack twice so
you don't really have the luxury of
doing this so King to be one first by
sheriff and now comes Luke 8 e8 getting
the other look into the game as well
preparing to start pushing the e4 pawn
we see captures on b5 grabbing this pawn
now comes Knight B captures on d5 and
Queen to b3 so what do you play here
here karana plays the very interesting
move well it captures here is other the
question for the moment because there is
this attack on the night here with the
Queen and the rook and also the bishop
can just capture back here and the Queen
is still on d7 but here Queen to b3 is
played and the hero is asking Corona
what do you want to do
waited the night here I'm just gonna
capture with the rook what Khurana says
be my guest
he plays efore and here Shiro has to
decide whether he wants to give up the
rook for two nights
and of course of course he wants to do
that why not he plays a root dr. Sundy 5
we have night captures on d5 and Queen
captures on d5 and he captures an f3 so
here karana created a very strong past F
pawn and if he can double rooks on the
e-file he will definitely have
compensation for his sacrifice material
and the question is if white can capture
on f3 it will be very good for him the
problem is he can because of rook to e1
check and once the King moves now a
captures on b5 and well after this row
comes to c8 you will have no ways of of
defending here so shiro goes back Queen
to d2 he doesn't allow karana this rook
to e1 check which is very important and
now rook to e4 preparing it to double
rooks and also the rook is just very
strong there we have looked the g3 by
Sheriff it's it's a very tricky move but
Khurana finds a very nice way to counter
it he plays Queen to e6 he says ok be my
guest grab the f3 pawn I dare you and he
dares him correctly because if rook
captures an f3
then rook to e1 check into c2 and the
Nook captures on f1 this is just the
beautiful stuff rook captures on f1 and
now Quintus e4 check will pick up that
rook and black ends up being of the
exchange with a much better position so
you cannot play rook captures and f30
finds Bishop to d3 just the bishop will
no longer be a target here and here
karana has to find a move so feel free
to pause the video here and try to find
the best move for Fabiano in this
position well I give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on finding
a very secretive move that Caruana
missed over the board and for those who
just want to enjoy the show there are
actually two good moves here so first
we're gonna check out the more forcing
one which is rook to e1 check but it's a
it's a really sneaky line for example
King to see two you have to move the
King and now eight characters on b5 of
course you are preparing rook to c8
this night will come under a lot of
attack
ruk captures an f3 rook the c8 and now
Bishop captures and b5 to defend the
knight but it doesn't work because of
rook captures and c6 and now you have
problems you cannot capture because of
rook to e2 just wins the Queen so here
black would just be winning
so rook the rook to e1 check is is a
pretty forcing winning sequence which
which karana missed after Bishop to d3
but there is another one a less forcing
line but also an enjoyable one it's a
captures here which just asks white what
are you gonna play here the point is if
you capture the bishop for example the
rubbish of capture sunny for you get
Queen captures on e4 with check King to
a 1 and now not grabbing the knight but
instead rook to e8 first you get the
rook into the game threaten mate Queen
t1 followed by captures rook after sunny
one will be made and after white create
some breathing room for Ace King now you
go Queen to e 2 you attack the Queen
Queen captures pawn captures and now the
only way to prevent queening is rook to
g1 you bring the Queen into the game
rook captures rook captures with check
and you have this endgame where black is
of course completely winning 5 points to
4 and of course a rook against a knight
so the product the point is after a
capture Sun on b5 you cannot capture the
roof you can go rook to g1 to prevent
rook to e1 but now the real magic
happens
you get Queen to d5 an extremely hard
move to find where you're attacking the
knight here and also if you move the
rook then the bishop will also be under
a lot of stress so rook the c1 defending
the knight and not f2 this is total
annihilation white will create some
breathing room for asking but it doesn't
help
rook the e1 and now you cannot straight
here because after all the trades anyone
just Queen captures and d3 will be
winning so nice the B for attacking the
Queen and attacking the bishop but now
f1 and now you bring a queen into the
game so black has two queens now what do
you play here rook captures on e1 and
now you just move the Queen rook F to G
2 and you attack white screen which is
undefended so you have to block this
rookie - but now Queen - h1 check rook
to e1 blocking again and
now just queen D as this queen is still
under attack by the knight you bring the
Queen to g2 and now why it's pretty much
without a move you still have two queens
White's queen is under attack
there is no good move here Queen d1 will
just be met with Queen captures on h4
and black keeps the two queens so really
exciting stuff after this Bishop to d3
move both the rook e1 and eight captures
on b5 are winning four Caruana but you
have to work it out and well the players
are reaching time control they still
have to make nine more moves and fear of
is a very long on the on the clock so
probably karana did not wants to
overthink this position and if you know
if you find 19 nothing then you just
gives you more time to think about what
to do so here karana played rook to e3
the rook is no longer a target here you
also guard the f3 pawn but okay those
are all things that weren't even threats
but like I said probably playing on
unsure of time hero now takes this
opportunity to play rook the g1 now
taking care of the rook e1 check idea
with f2 by Caruana and now rook the c1
so now Shiro is guarding the back rank
and also keeping an eye on the knight on
c6 so none of the idea does and ideas
that worked previously work now finally
a character son b5 by Caruana and now
comes Knight back to be for bringing the
knight back into the game and rooked f3
now karana puts the rook behind the
passed pawn and if the bishop and rook
at some point will not be guarding the
f1 square will be deadly for white
Bishop captures on b5 by sheriff and now
Queen the e4 with check and here you
have to be very careful Bishop to d3 the
bishop will be overloaded it's a very
sneaky move because here you play f1 you
bring a queen or even better a knight
into the game and this is very tricky
because now if Bishop captures Knight
captures with check now King cast the
movie if you pick up the bishop and you
end up being up a whole rook so you have
to be careful here sheriff plays Knight
the c2 blocks with the night and here we
have looked the c8 just piling up on
that night here
Bishop the a6 attacking fear of his rook
and here corona says just just says okay
that the bishop is overloaded you you
can't really capture my rook he just
pushes d5 and now yes you cannot capture
because the bishop has to keep an eye on
the f1 square what what you could do is
but it's also a very high achieving move
rook to f1 this is one possibility that
that share of missed this forces Bobby
to move the ropes now that there is a
threat of Bishop captures here so after
the rook moves now you move the bishop
attack the other look as well and when
this rook moves now you bring it back so
you basically get the same position for
your Bishop and b5 but you really
misplaced blacks rooks so one of the
options that was possible but sheriff
creates a threat differently fear of
plays a3 he creates some breathing room
for King and now Bishop captures and c8
becomes a threat or does it here Fabi
plays d4 continues pushing the the
passed pawn and he says okay you can
capture my rope
sheriff captures it as it is the best
move here and now f1 Queen we have
grouped after some f1 rope captures on
f1 now this is not losing because a3
also created some breathing room for the
king and now d3 so far by now has an
extremely dangerous past deepen and he
also has a very strong past f1 if he
manages to start pushing it with night
step III by sheriff and now comes Luke
to f3 just going after that night and
here you have some problems with white
so it's not easy to play something you
can't move the knight even though you
are about to lose it you can't move it
because Queen to c4 check will pick up
the bishop and see it you don't want to
allow this missed an arrow there so what
can you do how do you how do you
continue this position again feel free
to pause it and find the best move for
sheriff in this position so for those
who were able to do it
congratulations and finding such a such
a wonderful move and the photos you just
want to enjoy show its Bishop captures
on f5 you prevent the rook captures on
e3 and you force Queen captures on e3 so
this is what Bobby played for you played
Queen captures on e3 and now Queen to a5
saying that okay you capture my bishop
you're getting made it as your back rank
is very weak so here Bobby goes back
with the Queen Queen to d8 and now comes
Queen to d5 a beautiful centralizing
move
with the Queen keeping an eye on this
diagonal so no no sneaky checks are
possible keeping an eye on the queening
square attacking the rook on f3
defending the bishop on f5 it's just
just a beautiful centralizing move with
the Queen and it was in this position
that a wild Magnus appeared in the
background as you can see there's the
wild Magnus in the background checking
out this position on the board and a lot
is happening here you know who's better
here who is trying to trick who it's
always very exciting when the world
champion hovers over your board you're
always very proud if you have a good
position and I believe Shearer of after
playing Queen to d5 was very proud of
his position you can see even even
Carlson is trying to make out what's
what on the board so what is what on the
board dad that's a very good question so
how do you continue this you are up the
exchange as black but but how can you
how can you make progress here Fabi
tries Queen to g8 he tries a trade in
Queens and of course fear of declines he
plays a bush of the e6 pushes the Queen
back Queen to f8 and now h5 now she
rough starts attacking you cannot pull
the pawn the Queen will just capture it
now you can't move the Queen from f8 the
roof will fall so what can you do here
well
Fabi now goes rook to e3 just putting
pressure on the bishop here also getting
drunk out of harm's way and here what do
you do do you continue the attack do you
play a slow move do play g6 do play h6
well h6 is very interesting but with h6
on the board now d2 becomes a
possibility because rook to e3 is
basically preparing d2 now the Queen
cannot capture it because you lose the
bishop on e6 and if H captures on g7
with Czech you will capture with the
king and now for example Queen d7 check
the King comes to g6 and there are no
checks anymore all the squares where you
can check the black King are covered so
what can you do
still you have problems defending your
Bishop Bishop back to b3 of course you
want to guard the queening square as
well but now Queen to f2 will be very
strong and well you could check the
black ink a little but then the pawn
falls the King will slowly but surely
make his way down the board and I think
that it's it's hard to say if white will
be able to hold this so h6 although it
seems like the most
siding move doesn't really work so
should have plays g6 instead and Fabi
continues with his plan D - we have
Bishop the f7 by Sheriff just making
that queen useless not allowing the
queen to f2 and now we have rook to eat
to buy Fabi keeping an eye on the pawn
here and now Queen the d3 attacking
fabi's rook and here if Abby finds a
very interesting idea
Fabi plays Queen rook to H or H - you
have to keep an eye on this pawn and
also you want to get the rock out of
harm's way so here what you have to play
with white as share of is Queen to d4
just a move that keeps and high on this
pawn and also doesn't allow any sneaky
ideas by the rook of course you can
actually rope to h1 because of just
Queen captures here so here you could
try Queen to b8 preparing d1 Queen and
then Queen captures and beat you with
checkmate as the rock also will be
attacking that pawn but then Bishop to
b3 just covers the d1 square and now
okay rook captures and h5 g captures on
h7 the game continues so this was a
shear whose best idea but sheer of
played Queen to f3 and now
Fabi gets a brilliant idea it's it's
just just a wonderful idea so feel free
to pause the video here it's not an easy
idea but if you find that you will feel
very good about yourself so a few
seconds as usual so for those of you who
were able to do it congratulations on
finding such a brilliant move and for
those of you who just want to enjoy show
its rook g2 now rubgy 2 is such a
multi-purpose move of course if the rook
is captured then just d1 Queen the
problem is Ruth the g2 is preparing rook
to g1 and this will guard the queening
square so how do you prevent this should
have played Queen to d3
now of course rook to g1 is impossible
because of just Queen captures but now
after after going to d3 we have Queen b8
and this is just a digital beautiful
stuff this was not played in the game in
the game after after Coronas rook to g2
she resigned the game as the reason
no defense here the reason is after
Quinta dd3 you get Queen to be eight and
now the same the only defensive idea
white had against this threat of d1
Queen and queen capture some b2
checkmate was Bishop to b3 but this no
longer works because the rook is not on
the h-file the rook is on the G file and
now you have worked the g3 and this is
the idea Queen from B eight guards g3
and this is incredible how Fabi made
everything work he found out that the
Ruby does not belong on the H file but
rather on the G file and when she
replayed the Queen two-three that
mistake then Fabi sorry about that
played that rook to G to move beautiful
move so once again congratulations if
you found it here there is no defense
one of the Queen moves you just trade
everything Queen captures Queen captures
captures captures and now now you
finally promote d1 Queen and that's
that's it ah
rook g2 beautiful move by Fabi and after
this victory against Alexis Europe in
round three Fabiano Khurana is now well
he has shirt for first place because
only Fabiano Caruana and wang hao are on
three points so all three victories and
they will face each other in round four
so definitely we're gonna cover that
game unless unless it's a real snooze
fest then we might not but if it's if
it's really good then or at least
interesting we will show it so yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
I would like to thank Peter Shaftoe for
a contribution to my channel if you
haven't checked out
tactical music video bye-bye hygge do
check it out the link to it will be the
first thing you will see in the
description below as usual you can check
to my previous videos here yeah let's
pretty much it thankful for watching and
I will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the chest calm Isle of Man
chess tournament checking up on your
wonderful suggestions as usual and so on
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day